now we looked before at what kind of
income what kind of any income it's kind
of two things together mainly to do mid
time we looked at hub alley hourly rates
of wages and then we looked like annual
or fortnightly or monthly starts Vanessa
called salary thank you very much okay
so generally speaking permanent loads of
staff or some like part-time coach now
Commission is very very different
okay it is classic capitalism how many
of you are history students yeah
wages and salary are very specialist
tradition is very capitalist because
what that's about is about trying to
craft a model of paying employees
it gives incentives to high performance
and when we say high performance talk to
me the sales performance in this context
of earning money ok this is where
Commission kind of takes over in places
where it's like look you know what I
have 30 employees and some of them I
created making sales and others not so
much
so I want to be able to reward the
people who are doing a better job and
the way this is achieved is by well how
would you finish this sentence you guys
have met Commission before how would you
articulate the way that it rewards
people who perform well they just said
even louder thank you
for example if you're in that real
estate it's your Commission is a
percentage booth like that
and then you sell out something very
good very good like crucial so this is
yes that's exactly right so what this is
achieved by is paying a percentage is a
three-month Hey
all of whatever they end up selling the
more they sell the more episodes Ln
obviously right so you might have say
you know why don't half two percent as
your Commission's right that doesn't
sound like very much one in a half or
two percent but if you're selling a
house and it goes for $800,000 what the
Hamid Reapers it's not that bad okay so
what that does is if you're effective if
you can make more sales then therefore
and you're going to get paid more
because the percentage would just grow
as your sales grow however can anyone
see if Kaveri weakness with this problem
a glaring problem for the employees okay
so if you have like maybe it's just a
bad month you know the UM the real
estate bug it just takes a dive or more
realistically you know it goes up so no
one's buying
okay now let's not your fault you're
just your humble salesperson and at the
mercy of the economic sort of climate so
therefore that's not fair on you okay so
as a concession and I'm going to say
this by the way you seasoned always done
right not all workplaces depending on
the context with dudes but mostly as a
concession workplaces will still pay a
set and out regularly kinda like a wage
try to like a salary workplaces will pay
what we call a retainer which is
regardless of sales you could sell
nothing and you still receive the
retainer would anyone like to hazard a
guess as to why it is called a retainer
what do you think it's repeating
hold on think about the contents right
this is being given to an employee who
sells stuff right what would happen if
they sell me this on nothing
yeah it's about retaining your job it's
about for the employers point of view
I'm retaining my employees I don't know
like lose all of my employees today
saying hey we're working here and we've
got paid for this month and zero last
month I've got to go else somewhere else
and actually get you notice an income
right this is about retaining your staff
so that when it's a good month which
seasons and they will continue to make
the sales because the most sort of our
muscle industries that you have an ebb
and flow okay so two pieces to this
right you've got them in another color
you have the percentage the percentage
is Parkrose and then you have the
retainer and that does it stays put and
it's not like a regular fee so the way
we say that mathematically is we would
say this is constant where is the
percentage since it varies like the more
you sell the more you earn and we call
this Mary